[Music]
opened in 1962 the TWA terminal also
known as t5 embodied the spirit of the
Golden Age of flying it was closed to
the public in 2001 and now sits
abandoned at one of the busiest hubs in
the world New York's John F Kennedy
Airport
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hidden 150 feet below Kansas City in a
270 million year-old limestone deposit
more than 1600 people work in the
world's largest business labyrinth
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
in the Old English seaside town of
Margate there's a mysterious underground
cavern adorned with millions of
seashells its winding passages stretch
more than 70 feet and are believed to
have been constructed in the early 1800s
but no one knows who built them or why
[Music]
this library is full of historic
treasures the Trinity library in Dublin
Ireland was founded in 1592 its most
famous area is the Long Room this 213
foot room houses 200,000 of the
library's oldest books the room is lined
with marble busts many of great
philosophers writers and people who
supported the college the long room is
also home to one of the last remaining
copies of the 1916 proclamation of the
Irish Republic the Trinity College harp
which is from the 15th century and the
Book of Kells an illuminated manuscript
of the four Gospels that is from the
eighth century it is the largest library
in Ireland and as a copyright library it
can obtain books and materials published
in Ireland for free it is the only
library in the country to hold this
right
[Music]
hidden away in the Tuscan hills of
northern Italy this beautiful Moorish
castle was built in 1605 but for more
than two decades it's been sitting empty
there are 365 rooms in the castelo de
summit so no one for every day of the
year the Moroccan style palatial villa
is a labyrinth of exquisitely tiled
rooms each one intricately unique
[Music]
the castle was once a luxury hotel
restaurant and bar but closed its doors
in the early 1990s
it wasn't until 2013 that a local
nonprofit committee was founded to help
raise awareness for the increasingly
decaying castle
they have no ownership of summits ah no
but they helped to arrange and promote
rare public openings in northern Italy
in the foothills of the Alps a
collection of temples dedicated to the
human spirit sit 100 feet below ground
[Music]
built in secret over a period of 15
years this is dom adore the temples of
humankind
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
in a small town outside Prague there is
a church adorned with the skeletons of
at least 40,000 people assembled in the
1800s each bone was stacked by a single
wood carver the bones are of people who
wanted to be buried on holy land and
this peaceful chapel is their final
resting place this is the said let's
ossuary also known as the burn church
[Music]
some of the greatest works of art are
just beneath the waves standing in just
25 feet of water off the coast of Cancun
Mexico the Moose AO sub Aquatic of the
arte is both a monument to human
creativity and the natural beauty of the
Caribbean reef ecosystem the museum is a
vast collection of underwater galleries
with over 500 sculptures many focused on
themes of human interaction and impact
on the environment the Marine Park where
the museum is located is one of the most
visited stretches of water in the world
with nearly 800,000 visitors each year
immense pressure is placed on the native
reef ecosystem that's why every
sculpture is made from cement suitable
for the growth of coral seaweed and
algae the many holes in the sculptures
make perfect homes for marine wildlife
to colonize and feed off the coral the
hope is that as nature continues to
colonize these statues they will
transform into massive reefs
unrecognizable for what they once were
and it's also attractive to humans it
has become one of the most popular dive
locations in the area hopefully
signaling a more prosperous relationship
between man and nature
[Music]